centuries have passed but our orders  remain steadfast in its sacred mission  to preserve the balance between man and  half-breed that balance is threatened by  a new contagion that our Belliard you  have no idea who you're dealing with  oh let's do ops  let's eliminate these godless rebels  once and for all  I need you to provide coming  we really believe the rebels are  collaborating with the half-breeds  they're converging from the hospital we  need to unravel this without arousing  suspicion coming  stop for a pint did you  by where are you going to finish what we  started this is no time for vengeance  comes your senses  this is madness you're putting the very  core of our order in jeopardy sir you  have to trust me you dance on the very  edge of insubordination Sonny  so I gotta hurt this matter is not yet  over that you can be sure  you